und jetzt das heute journal mit 1 wolf
und marietta slomka guten abend auf
neutralem boden in istanbul haben die
ukraine und russland heute miteinander
verhandelt und hätten dabei so heißt es
unter anderem von den türkischen
gastgebern bedeutende fortschritte
erzielt immerhin saß man sich erstmals
seit fast drei wochen wieder direkt
persönlich gegenüber und die russische
seite erklärte dass es seine angriffe
auf kiew und das weiter nördlich
gelegene cerny massiv reduzieren werde
das mag hoffnungen wecken aber sind sie
auch begründet was ist von den
russischen ankündigungen zu halten und
worauf könnte sich die ukraine überhaupt
einlassen viele fragen die wir im
verlauf der sendung analysieren wollen
zunächst berichtet kamera vier jahren
über die heutigen verhandlungen
die erwartungen im vorfeld waren gering
auf vermittlung des türkischen
präsidenten erdogan reden heute
russische und ukrainische gesamte in
istanbul miteinander vier stunden lang
es kommt bewegung in die gespräche
moskau sagt das volle vertrauen aufbauen
da die gespräche über die neutralität
der ukraine ihre nichtnuklearen status
und die zu gewährenden
sicherheitsgarantien konkrete formen
annehmen hat das russische
verteidigungsministerium entschieden die
militärischen aktivitäten in den
regionen um kiew und jenny hof deutlich
zurückzufahren
kein waffenstillstand schränkt der
russische verhandlungsführer eilig ein
und stellt ein treffen putins lenski in
aussicht unter auflagen
entgegenkommen auch von der ukrainischen
seite das land bietet seine neutralität
an umfassende international vereinbarte
sicherheitsgarantien auch von
mitgliedern des un sicherheitsrates
sollte die ukraine angegriffen werden
sollten die garantiegeber der ukraine
waffen und militärische hilfe zur
verfügung stellen und ihren luftraum
schließen wenn es uns gelingt diese
bestimmungen zu konsolidieren für die
ukraine ihren derzeitigen status als
blockfreien nicht nukleare macht
festigen in form einer dauerhaften
neutralität
auch über die krim über lohans gunther
metz könne man reden so das angebot der
ukraine gebietsabtretungen seien aber
inakzeptabel
ein diplomatischer etappensieg auch für
die so unterschiedlichen
verhandlungsführer mit den ski hier
links und arrangement hier rechts mit
den ski der putin treuen
ex-kulturminister als vorsitzende der
militärisch historischen gesellschaft
soll er die rehabilitierung stalins mit
betrieben haben sein gegenpart david
arrangement fraktionschef der see lenski
partei ein gebürtiger georgier der viel
geld in die ukrainische armee investiert
hat keinen waffenstillstand also heute
aber laut ukrainischen generalstab
sollen einzelne russische einheiten um
die hauptstadt kiew und der großstadt
genitiv abgezogen seien
gleichzeitig sollen die russische
truppen in der region auch militärisch
zurückgeschlagen worden seien hier die
straße von kiew nach ihrem team
auch wieder ein ukrainischer hand die
strategisch wichtige kurstadt trotz der
netz im osten nach vier wochen
russischer belagerung begrüßen die
einwohner ihre truppen
an den abenden kamen die russen in
unsere häuser unsere keller und haben
unser gemüse unsere kartoffeln und
unsere gurken gestohlen
woanders setzt russland seine angriffe
fort wie hier in nicola rief im süden
des landes ein verwaltungsgebäude wird
bei einem raketenangriff zerstört es
soll mehrere tote gegeben haben es ist
ein einziger albtraum da war ein mädchen
auf einer etage das gestorben ist was
soll ich sagen ich hatte sie noch umarmt
und bin dann raus
zurück in istanbul heute kommt ein klein
bisschen hoffnung auf die vorschläge der
ukraine sollen jetzt präsident putin
vorgelegt werden doch der krieg in der
ukraine geht weiter
us präsident joe biden hat heute dann
auch wieder mit den europäern
telefoniert um sich zu beraten mit olaf
scholz manuela khom den italiener draghi
und den briten boris johnson
nach dieser telefonkonferenz hat sich
der deutsche bundeskanzler dazu wie
folgt geäußert
die
lage ist unverändert sehr ernst die
russische aggression gegen die ukraine
fortgesetzt das muss trotz aller
verhandlungen festgestellt werden und
deshalb ist es richtig und notwendig
dass wir uns unter den verbündeten
austauschen was uns gemeinsam wichtig
ist dass es schnell zu einem
waffenstillstand kommt dass die dass
sich russland von dem ukrainischen
territorium zurückzieht und das eine
langfristige friedens lösung gefunden
werden kann
dann schauen wir noch über den atlantik
nach washington und schalten zu unserer
korrespondentin claudia bates claudia
wie werden die ukrainisch-russischen
verhandlungen von der amerikanischen
seite bewertet
wir werden sehen ist das was präsident
biden dazu sagt er wolle nichts
hineinlesen in diese ankündigungen
russlands wie es heißt die militärischen
aktivitäten im norden der ukraine zu
verringern die usa sind zutiefst
misstrauisch halten auch ein
ablenkungsmanöver oder ein spiel auf
zeit für möglich aussenminister blinken
fasst das so zusammen was russland sage
sei das eine was russland tun sei das
andere und letztere ist letzteres ist
das was für die us regierung zählt es
gibt geheimdiensterkenntnisse die einen
russischen strategie wechseln
untermauern man sieht leichte bewegungen
in richtung norden man hält es hier
allerdings nicht für einen wirklichen
abzug oder rückzug sondern geht davon
aus dass diese truppen innerhalb der
ukraine verlegt werden und dass es dann
möglicherweise anderswo zu grösseren
offensive kommen wird und deswegen hat
präsident biden mit den verbündeten
heute gesprochen den druck auf russland
durch sanktionen weiterhin aufrecht zu
erhalten ebenso wie die umfassende
militärische hilfe für die ukraine
was die us regierung sehen möchte ist
eine echte deeskalation ein truppenabzug
oder einen waffenstillstand und dafür
sieht man hier in den usa bislang keine
anzeichen dankeschön nach washington und
darüber über die verhandlungen und das
kriegsgeschehen der ukraine wollen wir
jetzt noch mit einem ausgewiesenen
experten für sicherheitspolitik sprechen
mit carlo masala professor an der
universität der bundeswehr in münchen
und jetzt aus hamburg zugeschaltet guten
abend herr mazal am schönen guten abend
habe es gerade gehört in den usa sieht
man das alles sehr skeptisch ähnliche
töne hörte man aus london wie betrachten
sie diese verhandlungen und das was dort
gesagt wird auch so skeptisch
also ich teile diese skepsis und man hat
das ja auch einen deutschen
bundeskanzler gesehen der noch nicht mal
ein positives wort über diese
verhandlungen verloren konnte wir wissen
ganz einfach nicht ob die russische
föderation auf zeit spielt ob sie
versucht ihre territorial gewinne im
osten und im süden sozusagen auszubauen
noch weitere territorial gewinne dort zu
erzielen wir wissen nicht ob die
russische föderation letzten endes jetzt
so optimistisch klingt allein aufgrund
der tatsache dass sie natürlich auch dem
gastgeber dieser gespräche der türkei
die sich intensiv um vermittlung bemüht
hat entgegenkommen will also es gibt
ganz ganz viele unklare fragen und die
offensichtlichen durchbrüche so wie sie
in dem bericht vermeldet worden sind
sind ja eher ich sag jetzt mal in den
leichteren fragen passiert die richtig
harten nüsse werden erst kommen wenn man
über die territoriale tät der ukraine
redet also über die beiden ob laste im
donbass über die krim und über die
landbrücke und das sind fragen da ist
man wohl heute keinen millimeter weiter
gekommen da wird dann auch präsident
selensky sehr schmallippig und sagt da
wenig zu schauen wir noch mal auf das
kriegsgeschehen man könnte auch den
eindruck haben die russen geben im
moment das auf soweit sie es überhaupt
aufgeben wo sie nicht voran kommen
nämlich unter kiew ja absolut das ist
letzten endes ist dass das eingeständnis
einer militärischen niederlage also man
kann diese stadt nicht umzingeln man
kann sie nicht einnehmen man hat sogar
den letzten tagen die erfahrung gemacht
und das hat sich ja heute auch in ihrem
bericht wieder gezeigt dass die
ukrainischen streitkräfte den russischen
truppen dort schwere verluste zufügen
das heißt man zieht sich dort zurück
wird die truppen aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach irgendwo anders
in dieses land reinbringen und das ist
kein entgegenkommen und kein goodwill
das ist eine nette formulierung für die
tatsache dass russland da einem
militärischen niederlage erlitten hat
und könnte sein dass er sich jetzt
versuchen neu zu formieren oder sich im
osten zu massieren um zumindestens an
diesem einen kriegsziel noch
festzuhalten ich gehe davon aus dass es
darum geht sozusagen das was man bisher
erobert hat zu halten vielleicht weil
die kämpfe werden ja während der
verhandlungen weitergehen das noch ein
bisschen auszubauen um eine bessere
ausgangslage zu haben für den fall dass
es dann wirklich gespräche über die
territorialen fragen gibt diese truppen
werden nicht aus der ukraine
verschwinden sie werde nirgendwo anders
hin zum kämpfen geschickt es geht ja
auch für den sagen wir bitteren
erkenntnissen der internationale
konfliktforschung der sie sicher auch
sehr intensiv beschäftigen dass es
bestimmte zeit punkte gibt an denen
wirkliche verhandlungen eigentlich erst
möglich werden entweder ganz am anfang
oder an einem zeitpunkt wo einer oder
beide seiten eigentlich schon nicht mehr
kann oder keine aussicht mehr auf sieg
haben ist dieser zeitpunkt jetzt
überhaupt schon gekommen ihrer
einschätzung nach
meiner einschätzung nach ist dieser
zeitpunkt zumindest aus der ukrainischen
perspektive nicht gekommen weil das
blatt dreht sich ja seit ein paar tagen
für die ukraine also wir sehen
gegenoffensive wir sehen sozusagen
begrenzte
gewinne der ukrainischen streitkräfte
letzten endes muss man sagen die ukraine
hat gerade erlauben sie mir das zynische
wort militärisch einen kleineren lauf
und von daher wenig incentives jetzt
damit aufzuhören weil je mehr sie gebiet
den russischen truppen abnehmen können
desto bessere bessere ausgangsposition
haben sie in verhandlungen
die russen ihrerseits haben natürlich
ein problem jetzt zuzugestehen dass ihre
militärische kampagne in vielen fragen
gescheitert ist von daher müssen sie
hier versuchen gebiete zu halten und
noch territorien dazu zu gewinnen
eigentlich ist es kein guter punkt
zeitpunkt für friedensverhandlungen
wenn sie sagen die ukraine hat gerade
einen anführungsstrichen militärischen
lauf dürfte das doch auch mit den
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen
zusammenhängen oder
das hängt entscheiden mit den
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen
zusammen ich meine wir haben gesehen
dass die ukrainischen kämpfer eine
unglaublich hohe kampfes moral haben und
auch die kämpferinnen wir haben gesehen
so zu sagen dass diese armee
relativ gut ausgebildet ist aber die
waffenlieferungen die massive
unterstützung die die nato staaten der
ukraine zu teil werden lassen sowie die
aufklärungs ergebnisse die die ukraine
von den amerikanern bekommt und ich gehe
davon aus auch taktische beratung tragen
entscheidend dazu bei dass diese armee
nicht von den russischen streitkräften
überrollt wurde interessante frage ist
dann was der westen künftig noch tote
hat ja die ukrainische seite
präsident seelands gern an interessanten
vorschlag auf dem tisch gelegt
neutralität nicht weitere zur nato wenn
westliche nicht nur westliche sondern
dachten zum beispiel auch in china
sicherheitsgarantien gegeben werden
ähnlich wie bei dem nato artikel 5 also
automatischer bündnisfall wenn jemand
die ukraine angreift müssen alle anderen
sofort reagieren das ist eigentlich so
eine art nato lightly wie konnte man das
umsetzen das ist so eine art motto light
um mir fehlt aber leider gottes die
fantasie um mir vorzustellen wie das
umgesetzt werden kann aus dem einfachen
grunde nehmen sie die debatte um die
flugverbotszone die die nato ist nicht
bereit diese flugverbotszone aus gutem
grund zu errichten weil sie einen
kriegseintritt gegenüber russland
bedeuten würde warum sollte sie das in
zukunft tun russland bleibt ja weiterhin
eine nuklearmacht sollte russland die
ukraine nochmals überfallen aber der
warum abschreckung dann in zukunft
ja aber diese an diese abschreckung muss
ja dann letzten endes auch mit leben
gefüllt werden und solange die russische
föderation davon ausgehen kann dass die
nato kein interesse und keinen appetit
hat in einen krieg gegen eine
nuklearmacht einzutreten ist diese
abschreckung ich sag mal schall und
rauch und dazu kommt ja auch noch china
ist ja auch noch part dieser dieser
garantie mächte würde china in einen
krieg gegen die russische föderation
eintreten das vermag ich mir nicht
vorzustellen also von daher finde ich
diese ausgehandelten
sicherheitsgarantien ja sie sind härter
als das budapester memorandum das ist
sicherlich ein fortschritt aber wie es
im falle einer erneuten russischen
aggression dann sozusagen umgesetzt
werden könnte dazu fehlt mir gegenwärtig
die fantasie oder testanwendungen
vielleicht noch ganz kurz erklärt das
war 1994 als die ukraine atomwaffen
abgegeben habe es gab
sicherheitsgarantien von den usa den
briten und heute sehen wir was wir
daraus was daraus geworden ist er
professor salerno zeit schon um wir
hätten da noch so viel anderes zu
besprechen aber für heute und herzlichen
dank ich danke ihnen
von den menschen die jetzt innerhalb der
ukraine auf der flucht sind oder das
land bereits ganz verlassen haben haben
viele furchtbares erlebt die plötzliche
aufgabe ihres zu hause und alptraumhafte
szenen bilder und auch geräusche die
sich ihnen in die seele gebrannt haben
mütter etwa die mit ihren kindern
fliehen funktionieren erst mal müssen
sie ja auch und sie wirken deshalb auch
nach außen oft ruhig aber hinter der
stirn läuft andere st posttraumatische
störungen sind den kriegsgebieten
allenthalben ein gewaltiges thema
übrigens auch für soldaten und
soldatinnen oder für professionelles
medizinisches personal
molina hat eine deutsche trauma
psychologin getroffen die an der
polnischen grenze
ukrainische flüchtlinge betreut
nur zehn kilometer von der ukrainischen
grenze entfernt der bahnhof in der
grenzstadt chemische im südosten polens
ukrainische familien hauptsächlich
frauen und kinder stranden hier erstmal
nach einer langen flucht ärzte liane
wird aus heidelberg bietet ihnen eine
weiterreise nach deutschland an der bus
ist auch schon da eine sichere bleibe
für die nächsten monate alles ist
organisiert
doch die frauen zögern einfach ist es
nicht für die ärztin sie zu überzeugen
mit zu kommen allein einfach schon der
gedanke dass die diesen platz verlassen
löst bei denen trauma aus weil die
denken und hoffen dass alles aufhört
dass das einfach ein falscher traum wahr
und die erahnen da und hoffen und sagen
nein vielleicht könnten wir noch ein tag
aber die kinder sind schon erschöpft die
sagen wir wollen duschen können nicht
mehr liane wird die selbst ukrainische
wurzeln hat schafft es nach langen
gesprächen mehrere familien mitzunehmen
es geht nach bammental
berg zwei wochen später ein besuch in
ihrer praxis wie geht es den
geflüchteten frauen und kindern hier
wird fällt auf wie belastend die
situation für sie immer noch ist
die ärztin besucht die ukrainischen
frauen und kinder im familienzentrum
dort spricht sie ihnen mut zu
unterstützt sie keine leichte aufgabe
während sie immer schlechte nachrichten
aus der heimat bekommen
ihrer zeigt videos die er man geschickt
hat er verteidigt sein dorf in der nähe
von bonn jetzt versteckt sich im keller
wenn die luftangriffe kommen
wir mussten fliehen wir wurden
bombardiert wir mussten einfach weg von
den bomben
auch die ukrainische journalistin julia
hat gerade eine schlimme nachricht
erhalten aus dem völlig zerbombten ihr
pin
markiert worden und ein teil von dem
haus ist komplett kaputt die leute
machen
ladendiebe handy ist auch durch die
autobatterien die sie irgendwo finden
und genau und da ist jetzt seit drei
wochen eine absolute notlage und seit
einer woche richtig schlimme kämpfer
jetzt wie es weitergeht wissen sie nicht
wann und ob sie ihre männer wiedersehen
ist ungewiss mit dieser ungewissheit und
angst müssen sie hier in deutschland
leben doch sie lernen hier wieder einen
alltag zu leben allein schon für die
kinder
nachher im heute-journal update gibt es
noch ein gespräch mit markus beko dem
generalsekretär von amnesty
international deutschland über die
flüchtlingssituation und den vorwurf
russischer kriegsverbrechen
zugleich gibt es weltweit noch ein
weiteres großes thema bei dem sich
hierzulande die politische diskussion
darüber gerade auch wieder zuspitzt
corona damit beginnen die nachrichten
man hat es wolf diskutiert wird weiter
über die schutzmaßnahmen die meisten
bundesweiten vorgaben laufen am
wochenende aus und nun stecken immer
mehr länder ihren künftigen kurs ab
mehrere landesregierungen beschlossen
die möglichkeiten der basis
schutzmaßnahmen zu nutzen unter anderem
mit begrenzten masken pflichten bei
einer drohenden überlastung der
gesundheitsversorgung sind nach einer
hotspot regelung auch weitergehende
beschränkungen möglich und jetzt zu den
corona zahlen das robert koch institut
meldet 237
1352 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 15 1272 mehr als vor einer
woche
307 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents steigt leicht auf
1.700 3,3
in israel hat es am abend erneut einen
anschlag gegeben mindestens fünf
menschen wurden getötet als ein mann in
einem vorort von tel aviv gezielt das
feuer auf passanten eröffnete wie die
polizei bekanntgab polizisten hätten den
täter daraufhin erschossen
es war der dritte anschlag binnen einer
woche
die bundesregierung will natürliche
ressourcen wie moore wälder und mehrere
stärken um ihre klimaziele zu erreichen
bis 2026 sollen dafür vier milliarden
euro ausgegeben werden dass sie das
aktionsprogramm natürlicher klimaschutz
vor dessen eckpunkte
bundesumweltministerin lemke heute
vorstellte dazu gehören etwa die
renaturierung von mooren wie auch
maßnahmen zum verbot von holzeinschlag
in öffentlichen wäldern lob für das
programm kam von der deutschen
umwelthilfe der union hingegen fehlt ein
gesamtkonzept für den klimaschutz
ein dreiviertel jahr nach der
flutkatastrophe in teilen von
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
hat bundeskanzler scholz die betroffenen
regionen besucht in bad münstereifel
informierte sich scholz mit
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst und
bundesinnenminister über den stand des
wiederaufbaus im anschluss fuhr scholz
weiter ins rheinland pfälzische aartal
wo er gemeinsam mit ministerpräsidentin
dreier mit betroffenen sprach in folge
der überschwemmungen kamen insgesamt
182 menschen
naturkatastrophen klimawandel krieg und
pandemie es mangelt wahrlich nicht an
themen die die menschheit aufwühlen und
die nicht so alleine wieder verschwinden
werden oder sich wegdiskutieren lassen
und gerade auch die pandemie hat uns ja
die verletzlichkeit global verknüpfter
lebenswelten vor augen geführt wenn die
chinesen jetzt in der
wirtschaftsmetropole shanghai wieder
einen radikalen lockdown verhängen um
kroner infektionsketten zu durchbrechen
betrifft das auch uns stichwort
lieferketten und weltkonjunktur wie es
in shanghai aktuell zugeht berichtet
unser korrespondent ulf röller und einst
schon vorab gesagt speiseöl hamstern ist
dagegen harmlos
die drohnen flüge über die 26 millionen
metropole shanghai zeigen eine
geisterstadt das leben erstickt vom
corona virus die hälfte der stadt ist im
lockdown hier bewegt sich nichts mehr
am boden sind die vielen staatlichen
helfer bemüht alles im griff zu behalten
es soll keine panik entstehen sie
organisieren die essens vergabe denn
millionen von menschen können nicht mehr
einkaufen
was machen sie wenn die lebensmittel
ausgehen ich schlafe einfach dann habe
ich keinen hunger mehr
die realität in shanghai ist bitter
videos im netz zeigen wie die menschen
um nahrungsmittel streiten wie sie alles
leer kaufen weil sie angst haben dass in
ihrer quarantäne nicht genug zu essen
bekommen
scheiße hier sagt der mann der diese
bilder dreht ich bin im supermarkt und
alles schon ausverkauft
in shanghai gibt es 20 großmarkthallen
17 haben die behörden wegen corona dicht
gemacht manche supermärkte öffnen nur
nachts um den ansturm zu begrenzen er
geht um 23 uhr einkaufen
die bürden spinnen wir einfachen leute
müssen jetzt nachts einkaufen gehen wir
seit gestern dürfen viele millionen
menschen nicht mehr ihr haus verlassen
shanghai hat in der letzten woche 16
1500 neue fälle gehabt die null kowitz
strategie kommt an ihre grenzen mit
massentests und immer mehr kontrollen
wollen die behörden die omikron welle
stoppen
mein gefühl ist es wird immer
schwieriger virus ausbrüche zu
verhindern zum einen ist das omikron
virus so ansteckend und zum anderen die
menschen werden langsam der ständigen
kontrollen müde
glück hat wohl wer in einem solchen
provisorischen corona hotel in einer
messehalle landet ein gigantisches
bettenlager für positiv getestete mit
verpflegung und angeschlossener
medizinischer versorgung wer sein
viertel aber nicht verlassen darf hat
schwierigkeiten einen arzt zu sehen
was machst du wenn du krank bist dann
kann ich nur online mit dem arzt
sprechen
die behörden bauen nun einen grenzzaun
zwischen shanghai und der nächsten
provinz damit niemand rein oder raus
kommt china fürchtet die omikron welle
wie eine feindliche invasion
ja und mit den weltwirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen des shanghai lockt das
gesetz bei heinz weiter die maßnahmen
kommen zu einer ohnehin wirtschaftlich
angespannten zeit und china ist ein
wichtiger motor der weltwirtschaft frank
bethmann gibt es schon konkrete
auswirkungen am unmittelbarsten spürt
man die auswirkungen am ölmarkt was wenn
noch weitere chinesische großstädte in
den walk down müssen was wenn die
chinesische nachfrage generell einbricht
der rohölmarkt der zuletzt jaffrey
florierte reagiert auf solche
befürchtung stets sensibel die sorte
brent verbilligt sich bereits seit
freitag signifikant der preis ist
seitdem um siebeneinhalb prozent
abgerutscht doch damit nicht genug
shanghai ist eine finanzmetropole
internationale investoren ziehen gerade
ihr geld ab weil sie befürchten dass
große teile der wirtschaft zum erliegen
kommen an der börse vor ort wie im
containerhafen im übrigen der größte der
welt läuft der betrieb zwar trotz
ausgangssperre weiter und doch dürfte
die schifffahrt wieder einmal besonders
betroffen sein in shanghai ist
partnerstadt in hamburg stellt man sich
bereits jetzt auch verzögerungen 1 im
hamburger hafen geht man davon aus dass
in sechs bis acht wochen weniger schiffe
mit chinesischen containern ankommen
werden die deutsche wirtschaft insgesamt
sorgt sich vor weiteren lieferengpässen
und erneuten störungen der
produktionsabläufe
auch weil jede menge deutsche
unternehmen in shanghai und umgebung
ansässig sind zu diesem tag gehört aber
auch dass sich der dax deutlich um über
400 punkte erholte es sind die hoffnung
auf eine mögliche waffenruhe in der
ukraine die das aktienbarometer heute
getrieben haben frank wittmann vielen
dank
mit einem gedenkgottesdienst haben in
london königin elizabeth die zweite und
ihre familie an prinz philip erinnert
der ehemann der queen war vor knapp
einem jahr kurz vor seinem 100
geburtstag gestorben die 95-jährige
monarchen kann man arm ihres sohnes
prinz andrew in die westminster abbey
es war der erste größere öffentliche
auftritt der queen seit ihre corona
infektion bei dem feierlichen
gottesdienst an dem 1800 gäste
teilnahmen wurde vor allem die
wohltätigkeitsarbeit von prinz philip
gewürdigt
manche dürften sich vielleicht eher
dafür interessieren wer nicht dabei war
von uns was das im heute-journal gleich
folgt die reportage reihe 37° heute mit
einem thema das viele bewegt wie will
man im alter wohnen und leben und um 0
uhr gibt es dann unser heutigen update
mit christoph biermann bis morgen auf
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter mit eisigen grüßen
geht es in dieser woche mit dem wetter
weiter die luft kommt vom arktischen
ozean runter und wenn sie auf relativ
warmes wasser trifft und bilden sich
diese wolken straßen die teilweise
parallel ausgerichtet sind und wenn man
sie aus dem flugzeug fotografiert sieht
das so aus ja und von norden kommt die
luft dieser eisige polarluft und die
strömt allmählich südwärts und wird in
den nächsten tagen deutschland erreichen
noch ist dieses tiefe aktiv und bringt
regen und teilweise schnee in den bergen
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es
schon regenwolken mit dem tief was
allmählich ostwärts zieht auch richtung
nordsee gibt es regen sonst ist es aber
aufgelockert bei tiefsten temperaturen
einigen werten im osten minus zwei grad
und 10 grad im südwesten hier ist die
wärmere luftmassen noch vorhanden morgen
genau im süden viele wolken regen und
schon mal schnee in den höheren lagen
und auch richtung ostsee dazwischen
sonnenschein ganz im süden kann auch die
und da ein gewitter dabei sein
bei höchsten temperaturen von 4 grad
richtung vogtland und 15 grad maximal im
süden und richtung bayern hier also die
wärmere luftmassen die diese hohen
temperaturen noch mit trägt ja und am
donnerstag regen und schnee bei bis zu
vier bis elf grad freitag im süden vor
allem am alpenrand schneefall 1 bis 9
und samstag - 1 bis 10 grad das news
werte und an den alpen noch schneefall
ein schöner abend